[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
incredible Bobby Moynihan who you know
from Saturday Night Live AKA SNL ever
heard of it wonderful wonderful program
he's so funny and talented improviser
writer and performer and I've been
trying to get him on the show for years
and I'm so glad I'm actually glad we did
it when we did it because he's found so
much closure and so much wisdom and he's
really found a great cruising altitude
in his life and he's sharing some of
that with us here in this chat and I'm
so excited for you guys to hear it only
a couple things up top to talk about one
I am currently on the road go to
petehomes.com if you'd like to see me in
a town or city near you or if you're
going to be in Los Angeles I am there
once a month at Largo go to
largo-l-a.com and look for Pete Holmes
living at Largo always the highlight of
my month next one is on May 4th it's
going to be incredible edible but
petehomes.com for your general uh
touring needs
also only one Pete's pick here up top
this is Magic mind uh the way that I do
the ads here is I find products that I
actually use and I actually love like
magic mind something that changed my
life I saw it online I met the owner the
one of the founders James Bashar who's a
dear friend of mine he told me about it
he got me some I am absolutely uh I
don't want to say hooked because it's
not like I'm addicted to it but it has
changed my life it has made me more
productive and less stressed I can get
more done and with less resistance magic
mind is a Elixir basically it helps you
focus better on your work be more
creative and drink less coffee athletes
have Gatorade now creators have created
it is a mix of 12 functional ingredients
including matcha nootropics or new
atropics depending on how you say say
that that make you focus and adapt that
help you fight off stress so if you take
it in the morning with your coffee the
adaptogens round out the edge the edges
of that caffeine making you less jittery
from the coffee if you drink it on its
own you don't get wired at all you just
get dialed in it's basically Flow State
in a bottle you get 30 percent more done
on average that's five to seven hours of
thirty percent more productivity after
drinking this stuff helps you fight off
procrastination brain fog fatigue and
some ADD symptoms getting you into that
flow state it is wonderful a secret
weapon for me whenever I'm doing a
podcast or sitting down to write or just
sitting down to face my inbox which
always freaks me out magic mind gives me
the energy to do it it also calms me
down and gives me the focus I need to do
it and with a money back guarantee any
first first purchase will be refunded no
questions asked if it doesn't meet your
your expectations and we have a special
offer Go to magicmind.com weird and use
my discount code at checkout weird for a
limited 20 off your first order that's
magicmine dot Co slash weird and use
promo code weird for twenty percent off
and see what all the buzz is about all
right everybody let's get into our chat
with Bobby Moynihan get into it this is
great tell us about your Renovations
we bought a house got to be two YouTube
clickbaity yeah but Bobby Moynihan talks
about renovating his La house what
everyone needs and everyone clicks on it
and then they immediately cream their
jeans that's the worst headline ever I
can't don't give me I mean I'm I'm the
one getting me started but like when it
comes to the YouTube game like trying to
get people to care about a show that's
about like deep comedy
relationships love and the meaning of
life but like you have to be interested
in like talking about like God or
religion or whatever but you also have
to like look the other way when I say
come gutters like how do you find it's
how do you find that audience it's a
fine line it's a fine line between
between love and podcasts yes that's
right I don't know I know I'm just so
grateful for the people that we have I
couldn't begin to try and find the
people that listen to the show I'm just
so glad they're already here oh gotcha
because it's like changed as we've gone
I don't mean to start with a thesis
about this podcast no I love it I I just
was making sure we were talking about
the same thing I thought you just met
new people in general and I was just
like people forcing you to meet new
people well that's what I thought you
meant are you an entry or an extreme
introvert or extrovert oh I don't know
really I I think all right let me ask
you this yeah go ahead what here's how
another way to ask it sure we just
wrapped Saturday live
the one episode any episode
yeah maybe you go to the parties that
Sunday you're calling people to hang out
or are you just recharging no I don't
hang no yeah I'm the worst that might be
interesting I'm an anus You're an anus
when it comes to Friendship just wedged
between two letters no I I I'm I'm very
I'm very happy to go home always yeah uh
we've got the partying at SNL out soon
the last two years I don't I think I
went like like it was like the good
nights I had my book bag right off stage
my book bag it would actually just cut
to an episode of you on a bus going home
yeah it's like Miley Cyrus thank you so
much hard sound hard hard cut to me
silent
[Music]
[Laughter]
here's oh a nice heart place to start
I heard because you were one of those
dudes that was at UCB when I was at UCB
and you were one you were the first
person a lot of dudes at UC a lot of
dudes you were one of those beer
drinking soft white boys like me you
think I was really do you think that do
you think a beer drinking soft white is
that really your remembrance or are you
just trying to be everybody at UCB was a
soft white boy it was a lot of them had
beards
like there was an improv uh there was a
improv there's an onion there was at
least eight of me there were eight of
you yeah it was like me and Pat bear
John gabrist there was a lot of there
was a lot of use types yeah yes
and were there other gethers it's like
get a third Zach Woods like I think
there's only one guther yeah but at
least I'll call it the lovable pill dork
and I say that with love and I'd say
that of course it was in the room you
know what I mean it's like that's funny
my first thought was I'm more of an
Ernie and they're more of a bird
is Bert oh I'll take that he's Bert
you were I already used a second here
because I can see him at home watching
this well
I clicked the wrong Bobby Moynihan
renovates his house
[Music]
yeah no I love them all too but you okay
so I was there doing stand-up and you
got SNL and here's the hard opening uh
kind of lovely gratitude place because I
heard you say that you cried when you
heard your name announced
your name also I'm gonna blend into that
and then I'm gonna give it to you
like I'm warning you then it's gonna be
your turn
but I I still have SNL good night
streams that I'm doing the good nights
at SNL so I wanna I wonder if that
primes you did you used to have SNL good
night's dreams oh yeah yeah
and then getting it take take me through
for the fun of it but also just for that
that warm
you know what I mean like there we were
do you know what I mean I mean there we
were and you got us and I was crazy it's
nuts it's nuts to think about it's also
crazy to think about now because like
closer to SNL or like whatever uh
um talked about it a lot more now I
don't talk about it as much yeah so it
is crazy to go to go back I guess and
and start thinking about it because
you're especially in the context of like
um I don't like I said I don't talk to
many people yeah so like to talk to them
like you were around at that time like
it's like we were probably around each
other more at that time than we are now
obviously yeah
with the Muppets at the Hollywood Bowl
is that true yeah the last time we saw
it that was one person Gonzo was there
the best thing next time Gonzo's in town
Bobby yeah I would drop everything to
hang out with Gonzo not he's the Al
Pacino of the Muppets friends of mine oh
yeah of course yeah because you
understand he's the Al Pacino of the
Muppets is I completely disagree really
I just mean get out
who is he of The Muppets
he's a good the Gonzo at the Muppets
he's the most sizzlak of the Muppets I
mean
maybe Mo reads to the needy I don't know
if that's right tell me well I'm just
trying to think he's so like
insane and weird his whole thing is just
weird for weird's sake but also like he
loves a chicken he's he's a very open he
is that's what I was saying Moses
admitted he loves cross-dressing he
loves like you know like he's he's very
open I'm trying to think like I don't
know Al Pacino
okay Richard kind is the Fozzie or fazi
is the Richard that's a good one yeah
there we go
that's a really good one I just wanted
to get one right
you don't have to get it I'm not making
fun of Pacino's nose none of these are
shots right answers there's a right
answer shots fired on Pacino's nose but
Pacino's face reminds me of Gonzo that's
[__] up
I'm not gonna lie
if I were Al Pacino I would never listen
to you do comedy again Paige
oh you want the books come on in there's
literally oh family at the window
no it's it's Paige who works with me
come on in Paige
you interrupted a perfect dude hi hi
baby oh my God she's so hello get real
nice to see you hi Haley
yeah of course yeah my pleasure
bye just Paige picking up a stack of my
books just as I was about to it's hard
to find an opportunity where you can
organically do your best impression
which is Al Pacino and it was that
window and now it's gone I disagree you
think it can come back I wish somebody
would do an Al Pacino impression right
now but I can't remember what the setup
was we were saying you said Al Pacino
looks like guys
well I picked the wrong link to click
today
not bad I I like that he put it on
himself and didn't get mad at you I like
that yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you made him a very my Curious fingers
he's on an iPad press the wrong Square I
could I'm not gonna do an Al Pacino
impression this is my opportunity
hi everybody hi everybody yeah well
you're getting this sing song I'm doing
what hater does which is Scent of a
Woman Pacino if you watch Frank Caliendo
he does real
Pacino's meaning there's the way he
actually talks and there's the way we
want him to talk which is outside that's
that's it's like it's like taryn's Brad
Pitt yeah Taryn kill him I didn't know
he did Brad Pitt oh it's my favorite he
did it on this one all the time but he
would just do it and then at the end of
a sentence he would just go
that and it was just like he would
always just add in a weird bread pit
kind of sound and it wasn't I don't
think Brad Pitt does that but it just he
does it's pretty much if he should do it
now if not yeah my favorite is like
slightly exaggerated weird impression
nobody wants the real guy
I saw on your Wikipedia that you did
just telling you how I found it but I
haven't seen you do Jonah Hill but it
said you do Jonah Hill and I was like I
don't even know what a Jonah Hill sounds
like uh that's really weird every all
Impressionists talk about Bobby
moynihan's Jonah Hill impression it's up
there with Rich Little
and that's it
but I can't even hear him it was
99.6 costume and wig
and uh and four and four percent the way
I actually look
just looked I might have just been the
largest and what's funny is I'm hearing
how your potential to do Seth Rogen
because it might just be I did something
yeah is it well for that it's uh I'm I'm
not I'm gonna go as far as saying I'm
never gonna try and do an impression on
camera again really it was never your
thing never liked it well I think it the
opposite like I loved like weird like my
favorite thing to do in an improv show
is to like make someone Sinbad or like
you know what I mean just like and I
don't care what they do I just want to
see them do it like you know like I love
like I think I scored with like the best
you'll know if it's wrong
but you don't know how to make a Vibe
with Sinbad positive and psyched and
confident and confidence
he did the spot and he said he's never
bombed I'll never forget it he says I've
never bombed and he's right I believe
he's right too I actually believe him
because bombing is an agreement you
enter in with the audience and if he
doesn't sign you have to serve papers to
a comedian to get him to agree that he's
bombing and Sinbad just never that's why
his name is Sinbad it's not his legal
name I think that's I love him I love
him with all my heart I always have yeah
meet central place in my heart me too
person bad is this real yes very much so
he was one of those guys that when I
watched when I was young I was like
we're about the same age I watched a
special and I was like I don't know
what's happening there's comedy growing
up I mean like yeah like he embodies it
he's not doing it in the way that
Seinfeld's doing it he just is it uh
he's just a funny guy I wrote a schedule
for SNL with a with a couple people uh
Christine nangle and uh uh oh my God I'm
blanking um whatever
um uh called Kings of Catchphrase Comedy
where like I got to play essentially
like a smash between Sinbad and um
do you ever hear of Chucky ducky yeah
quack quack yeah yeah I played a guy
named Slappy Pappy who just ended every
joke by saying Slappy Pappy and it was
ju and just making weird sounds and uh
it was just because I wanted to dress
like Sinbad and and have a good time
because
obsessed with Chucky ducky quack quack
mullaney hamburger mullaney came up with
uh the best joke in the entire thing
which is Keenan Thompson plays a guy
plays it was kind of after hamburger who
came to the show one night that we did
the sketch which was nuts but wait
hamburger was in there at the show
because we did it a couple times and he
came back because of it Keenan played a
guy named uh David beef jelly Winfield
which I just Dave Winfield was on the
Yankees and I just thought it was funny
is that okay well yes very much so beef
jelly David beef jelly Winfield uh and
his catchphrase was Jason he would tell
a joke and John Bellini wrote his first
joke ever which was you ever come home I
catch a white eating dookie
you're white and he would just yeah
I catch your wife eating dookie and then
he would just go beef jelly and that was
it
and it was uh I think that was my
favorite joke ever I remember John
Mulaney saying that for the pitching
that and and um it's hard to separate
for a really long time his voice because
I can see him pitching it that's what I
mean
anything yeah and everyone's like this
is no not beef jerky that would make
sense beef jelly yeah
me pitching me not pitching me but
telling me I don't think he ever did it
but they were wanted to do a sketch
where it was I think it was Reverend Al
Sharpton doing a commercial for sushi
but he hates Sushi just one of the most
classic setups where he's going like
they have tuna tartar gross salmon
nigiri yuck he just he won't it's his
you just hear him saying it yeah yeah
exactly one of those one of those I
shared an office with him for the first
couple yeah we got hired together and we
shared an office together for like four
years three or four years see that's
interesting because Melania and I were
friends before that too so I watched
both of you cross over I was there like
when they used to do oh hello I was
their son who wanted to be a rapper
perfect in those early in those like
when we did a bunch at UCB like before
yeah oh my God that is bringing me back
yeah yeah watching them do that nobody
like I don't wanna
it's a patina line smell my own farts
but you know like enjoy my own story he
says it in Glenn Gary Glenn Ross he's
like
no he goes
he plays reeks of your farts for a month
that's right I was in Glengarry gun Ross
in college you were yeah who were you
the guy that gets all his money taken
James link yep you were James link that
I closed last night
[Laughter]
I think it was um and you a lot of your
lines are just my wife ellipses yeah
yeah there's a lot of that it was a lot
of what
um
I can't negotiate negotiate what the
deal the deal the deal is dead James so
you know it a little they know it a lot
better than me
I ran into one of the guys uh forgive me
for calling the the red-headed doctor
from Scrubs do you know this man's name
no yep then we're just gonna call I love
that you gave it a good
cause I had to think about it for a
second I think I know who you're talking
about but I don't remember any I think
I'm thinking of Neil the guy the janitor
guy no because you said Doctor oh yeah
the janitor guy we're talking about the
redhead what you said to make it
something yeah I want it yeah so you
could win Oh you mean Lassie the dog
that I know
we got to get back to Hamburger let's
not forget that sorry but I ran into him
no I ran into the Hamburglar what if him
what if the comedian hamburger was
kidnapped by the Hamburglar
now we're talking or if he was kidnapped
and you're a cop here's the scene
here's the scene I think we me and
Mulaney and Simon Rich wrote A Sketch at
SNL that did not get on with Anne
Hathaway where I was the Hamburglar and
sneaking back into the house and she was
my wife and she was in a black and white
striped nightgown oh my gosh actually
had abandoned mask on also and she was
just like where were you
and she was like you've been stealing
hamburgers again haven't you and the
whole thing was like the hamburgers
don't help us we don't we don't gain
anything from having more hamburgers
they only hurt you you need if you're
gonna if you're gonna live this way you
have to start thinking about the family
first it was just a very like wait like
steel actual stuff you have to steal
money
it was like it was like it was like that
it was like you have to go if you're
gonna steal it has to be because three
it did not get on
[Laughter]
but I think I wrote that with Simon and
John Mulaney I think as a gift you can
also pass will you be a cop
and I'm a cop and we realize that the
comedian hamburger has been kidnapped
and it's a very serious situation I just
want you to be a cop who thinks of the
joke do you think it was the Hamburglar
but is really trying not to you know
it's inappropriate
it does feel
like every cop would take the swing
though you think they would go for it do
you think yeah because they're chewing
gum and they're leaning on the cruiser
like before body cams definitely before
the body cam it was a [__] Open Mic
tell me
I wonder if cops know the name of the
guy who invented the body Cam and they
curse his name [__] that guy Doug
Stevenson like yeah I got Stevenson
oh [__] you Doug I've seen the clip
going around like the past month of the
the chief of police and like
Ohio or something that got pulled over
no he's hammered and he got pulled over
like a town over and he's just going hey
check
hey
the guy goes no I'm not turning the
camera he goes okay he just gets so
defeated he tried you go hey
camera turn it's real like adorable like
a child like he's just like trying to
get his attention that's like my
four-year-old daughter will go she'll
make a secret for no reason she'll go
let's not tell Mama that you brushed my
hair I have a secret yeah
medical body I'm gonna get back
up secrets are fun secrets are fun very
much so I just want to make a secret off
camera with you so we can have anybody
else knowing yeah this is very important
and then when you realize you have Dish
because I feel like you tell me
something Val just finds out I don't
know if you're that way with your wife
if I tell who something my if you told
me no no sorry jumping around moving the
subjects Mark no you are excuse me Bobby
thank you I'm self-deprecating I like
that yourself which by the way yeah
smart move
whenever I'm looking at my stand up and
I'm like something's off like I'm losing
them it's because I have to add it's
like a seasoning you go it's because I
made myself not the joke I'm I'm
attacking something else too much and it
just needs a Sprinkle of
call myself old PD or old Petey's not
the smartest guy it needs that it's very
different from other countries in
America specifically if you're if you
look like me I guess I think it has a
lot to do with how you look somebody
told me in Ireland the reason I mention
other countries is like if you're gonna
be uh a singer-songwriter or a poet
they're like you have to be depressed
you just have to like we won't accept it
if you're going around whistling this
accent is terrible going around
Whistling Dixie oh it's Scottish
they're like all the same you earn it by
being dour all day and then they'll go
like let's have us a poom sorry we're
all over the place as as we should be I
mean like I expected nothing less I this
is a day off for old homesick I'm gonna
tell you that right now okay so you're
smart and I was saying subjects and
secrets if you Bobby tell me don't tell
anyone but at night I drink paint
thinner right like it's just something I
love some people drink alcohol I sip
little bits of paint thinner and I go I
won't tell anybody I'm gonna tell Val
oh yeah yeah I'm a couple
you're not talking to one person right
now it's a couple
yeah I I got a job recently a job that
like you're not allowed to tell people
about yeah you know like you gotta sign
something that says you won't talk about
this it says I am Boba Fett and you have
to sign it go on
and
from the showrunner got a text and then
immediately sent a text to my wife that
said you're not gonna believe this I got
it and they cast this first yes of
course you did immediately to the
showrunner yeah and then was like I'm
now going to
go wait what first of all I'm sorry
to send it to my wife
I sent it immediately to the showrunner
and then sent him a text immediately
that said sorry that was clearly for my
wife like like you know by the way
like our legal system didn't hear a
thing about it it was like like it was
like that is understood I felt like it
was just like we understand that there's
certainly hope I can't think of them but
there are laws like it's built into our
league I think it's so funny that no
matter how many like Greek pillars we
erect and and we put on robes and we
bang fine wooden gavels and all this
stuff there's all these allowances for
The Human Condition in the legal system
and some of them have to do with like
well it was his wife or it was her
husband like you like if you're married
or if you're well she can't testify what
is it your wife and like people get
married and they're just like
that's what I would thank you for
knowing what I was talking about but
that's absurd that's absurd it's crazy
it's just their marriage well ladies and
gentlemen they have sex as you get older
don't you just find like it's it's ABS
everything's absolutely insane and
broken and has one every single thing
has one loophole yes like as a maybe if
it's even as a parent where you're just
like how do you tell this person I was
just thinking about that like today this
is a fact yeah because it might not be a
fact in two years or it might be or I
could be wrong I don't know like it's
all you're doing is you're
indoctrinating them into a conspiracy of
flimsy ideals yeah and that's what
culture is a conspiracy of flimsy ideals
like I was thinking about like I'm sort
of full of [__] when it comes to what I
eat like I was like I don't eat beef
I just for some reason I am beef
you're Shia LaBeouf I wish you wish you
were Shyla beef yeah you would trade
lives with Shia LaBeouf not Shia LaBeouf
Shia LaBeouf
a a Montreal street performer a Shia
LaBeouf in person a fat Shia LaBeouf
impersonator called shilibri called Shia
labeaf I would take his life
not like kill him no he wouldn't kill
this man you would he would face off
with him you could happily become I
would not murder him shy Le beef
it's not shya his name is s-h-y it's
correct and it's airbrushed on his card
it's shy I love beef
[Music]
I tweeted that once I was like I never
forget the Shia LaBeouf's name is
his business cards are double-sided just
in case wait wait which side is which
both they have both the same thing on
both sides because why would you have
one blank side
that seems like something that seems
like a cocaine idea like uh Like the
Wolf of Wall Street
The Wolf of Wall Street guy is like we
print it on both sides why are you
handing the one you got a 50 variable
they're not going to see your info I
don't this is the weirdest thing ever
and I don't know if I've ever thought
about it but the second my dad showed me
his business card ever I went like in my
mind child I went like why is it not on
both sides I don't know why and we're
back and I don't think I ever thought
about it again until this moment I love
that this happened
I envy you know the movie The Master
where they just sit around and they like
hypnotize each other and remember like
weird obscure memories no but when you
said the master the third the movie I
thought you were talking of is the one
with Dana Carvey where he's dressed as
the turtle the master of disgust
disguise can we please do a super cut
where it's Phil Hoffman and they may
they cut in scenes but it's he's talking
to him and he goes turtle turtle yeah
and it's the Master of Disguise
you listen to fly on the wall by any
chance dude and Dana occasionally
meetings like free therapy for me really
a little bit yeah it's like hearing
people talk about imagine if you had a
podcast where the best people who ever
worked at your job talked about it and
brought all like all the other people
who worked there yes about it right yes
that's like you're getting to listen in
without yeah it's it's crazy what did
you what is it that you were looking to
sell I get it but what were those
feelings that needed addressing
oh I mean how long do you have but but
what I was going to say quickly was uh
quite a while already spends 10 minutes
addressing on the last episode the rumor
that is going around the internet that
he found out about 9 11 while dressed as
the turtle on set and that they had a
moment of silence while he was in the
turtle outfit and he had to like address
the rumor that that didn't happen this
week and it just might be my favorite
peace of life my favorite room like
whoever started that or figured out that
the time I don't know what that is but I
love it who
I thought he had to address it seriously
was somebody that seems like a weed
thought like double-sided business card
sounds like a coconut a weed thought is
wait they were filming that in September
of 2001 like you can guess I'm trying to
figure out did somebody figure that out
and like that sounds like a very
brilliant mind got very baked and was
like these movies take about a year to
edit watching that movie picked up the
DVD case went in 2001.
I just started giggling
take off the glasses
what's the play
do you take them off
I think you
you
yeah
if there's a better outfit to hear about
a tragedy in
I haven't heard that's that's the only
member of the animal kingdom that's
ready for horrible news is the turtle
show me a better equipped animal he's
literally the master of it
so that's the best
911 turtle shell
thankfully
thank God
that is uh my favorite story uh but no
that podcast is fantastic
what's the Salve what's the Salve well
no it's just it's I I maybe this is just
the easiest sentence to say it's it's
it's really comforting to hear all of
these other people that you admire have
the same fears of course maybe that's
can you sentence for fun because I
guarantee I'm gonna relate what are the
fears what are these fears what's one of
them
well I mean like
I'm not getting on the show I'm I'm not
funny anymore do these people like me am
I an idiot yeah man you're honest like
on the show oh yeah yeah will they use
me I'm an idiot I'm a fraud well yeah I
mean all the I mean every fear in the
world you know it was it was my life's
dream it was all you know it was it was
like we
I still can't believe it and then all of
a sudden it happens and then you have to
navigate that and that was and like I
don't think I realized until after I
left
that how I navigated it or even if I did
at some times like yeah like I
definitely didn't realize
what was happening until I left and I
know that now yeah nine years yeah yeah
and then after you were like what oh
[__] almost almost instantly went like
whoa and then like went back recently
and it was just like flipping a switch
that hadn't that had been turned like a
nine year you've done something for nine
years and then you turn it off
immediately yeah and then you turn it
back on for one night
again
everything that I was afraid of went
away and it was just easy and fun and
wonderful and I was like ah man yes
you got the like it's almost like when
people have near-death experiences and
then they go like why are why is
everyone so worried like look at your
serious face oh I can't find parking at
the mall you know what I mean and
they're like you're alive so am I
hearing you right that when all the
stress was gone you got to do SNL like
Buddy the elf like a free person
I was like I think my my especially like
my last episode of SNL I got like like
really really sick the morning of it
like I was like vomiting like like on
the ground like I can't like if this was
any other this wasn't my last show I
would be calling out yeah and like got
super super sick and it wasn't the most
enjoyable it was now in retrospect like
it was perfect but uh but like that
morning I was not going I really this is
how I wanted it to end like you know
like it wasn't the culmination I was
hoping
your first time Jimmy part of uh Jimmy
Pardo when Jimmy John hosted
never not funny uh when Don Porter said
your name the first time he passed in
between but your first SNL you had
liquid coming out of your eyes your last
one well tears yeah yeah tears I don't
know what that sounded really liquid I'm
an alien it sounded accusatorial that's
something Mark Zuckerberg would say why
do you have liquid
this is illogical uh but then on your
last episode you had liquid coming out
of your butt and mouth
that's what I was trying to look at your
experience with liquid I was trying to
think if that was true and I was like I
think it was just my mouth just your
mouth no if it was my butt sometimes the
butt sits it out
and you know what definitely receiving a
little break respect a little guy gave
me a break that day he's dealing with
enough man well tell me about it right
yeah I can't believe you were puking
okay oh I was a mess I was a mess so we
were talking about then when you came
back
you were able to enjoy it don't let me
put words it was just like
you know the second you get SNL you
start thinking about leaving when you're
gonna host and like you know like the
50th like you know like it's like
there's all these you know things you
wonder or at least I did and do and uh
thank you for a moment that bird existed
in arguably
three consciousnesses Yours Mine and
Katie's I like to think that bird was
Lord Michael's telling me everything's
gonna be okay
tweet tweet
I mean you know it's like that thing
where you fly by Pete Holmes's house
[Music]
um what was I saying where are we what
day is it so you enjoyed it when you
came back and yeah it was like the first
time you think about the 50th you think
about hosting in the middle of the
pandemic I got a text that was like hey
you want to come do drunk uncle for this
cold open and I was like
like you know what I mean like it was
very much a very nice feeling after not
being there for a while and then my
second thought was we're in the middle
of the pandemic I don't want to get on a
plane like and then by Tuesday it was
cut and I was part of me was devastated
and part of me was extremely fine with
it yeah and like just that alone like
that thing alone of like well they asked
yeah I can take that with me and like I
think now I have learned the small
battles of SNL is just like
stop they asked yeah move on with your
life like now I'm better with not making
it emotional and making it like your
identity this is Saturday
you know now it's just like yeah it's
got great you say it like in torment boy
from New York oh God I probably have
I think your wife is like sweetie yeah
take a big breath
New York it's Saturday night in Anger
when the music comes on you can see my
shoulders and my wife were just like
it's like whenever we hear the music
it's like the text you couldn't be in
this a safer place you had your dream
come meaning this is right in my alley
you had your dream come true but now
in our uh 40s looking back I'm kind of
like it is a pressure cooker it is kind
of an insane not a careful what you wish
for but like there had to be moments
where you're like let me put it this way
let me ask you went back and you you saw
all these options completely different
perspectives just like
well I think it was like it's this thing
of like you get there and Lauren was a
little bit like you made it here like
the the job is over yeah like you know
like you did it now just act like it and
it's not that easy to say like he said
though essentially those words to me
yeah just act like relax and [__] act
like you belong yeah like kind of in not
in very more Lauren words yeah and yep
and remember thinking like okay pal like
that like oh I'll just do I'll do that
hold on one second let me go talk to
Paul McCartney yeah because how do you
act like what do you do like and that
but now as an adult and also somebody
who's gone through therapy and had both
their parents passed away and has a
child and like you know there's a lot
more life like real life experience
rather than just like and I wrote a
sketch this week where I'm a suit
salesman like like
um real actual problems you have other
tent pools you have others fence poles
like more property yeah I think therapy
alone changed everything what was it
what was that shift
realizing that there were maybe two
things that made me uh get SNL which is
like being funny and like being able to
take a mental beating yeah interesting
like being somebody who's like a
a good dumb Soldier yes yes I understand
or or or do you like some capacity like
like uh
this guy can withstand the insanity of
what's about to happen yeah he may not
know it is it because but like he can do
it he can withstand the the insanity so
many thoughts yeah one I feel exactly
the same way I'm wondering if you feel
like that's linked to your childhood as
I did I was like a Rowdy Saturday night
at a club is nothing compared to the
home's household two
um let's start with that one like do you
think it was like you were bred to kind
of withstand Insanity
like Jason Bourne
yeah I guess like I guess I didn't even
know that like uh in the year I finished
uh SNL ended I had been dating someone
since like before SNL
and we knew we were gonna get married at
some point but like the SNL ended uh got
married
um had a kid
and then my father and my mother passed
away six months after and apart so it
was like within a year they both just
like just like all these major crazy
insane changes wow had you craving that
Dana Carvey Turtle costume right and uh
uh
and like finally started going to like
therapy and like taking that part of
life super seriously instead of just
being like I'm I'm a fun
like you know this is who I am and like
you know started doing the work like
yeah like you know whatever and um
because it was hurting you I was in a
bed I was in a
I don't want to say like I was in a bad
place I was in a new place that was bad
that was awful
where I wanted to stab my eyes no just
you wanted to Equis yourself uh but you
were it was starting what I'm hearing
and what I want people to hear is there
comes a point where therapy isn't just
chit chatting with a doctor you go like
I need to un un uh not some of these
blocks in my psyche well it's gonna hurt
I guess only because I had only been
going for a little while it was like
when I first started I was just like I'm
just paying someone to complain to them
and then it was realizing that that's
not what I'm supposed to do that's what
I think that's what I did with my mother
right and you know and like that you
know like it's like it's it's it's it's
it's it's that put on a show a little
bit it's it's a little bit
um
I think what therapy a little bit taught
me and
it's I think this I I was trying to
explain this recently to my wife it's
like
there's you experience this thing that
you love but then you realize that the
thing that you love is not what it was
but then it kind of is
and then it's over yeah and then you
spend all this time thinking about that
thing but then you're like I need to
move on from that thing
and all this other life is happening now
I now I'm going off on a crazy tangent
but I hear you it sounds like SNL is
sort of like condensed milk it's like
you did a Showbiz career condensed into
nine years and all of that value and
identity that we get from this external
affirmation system that is our work you
got yanked out of it and he also crammed
it like they were making liver pate out
of you like it got funneled into you in
nine years and then your booted not
booted but you you're out and you have
to deal with that like who am I like you
had like an existential
yeah I think it's like it's like
when I look back now it's like when I
was 15 I was 25.
when I was 25
I was
30 in my like I was I was making like
you know like whatever but then in my
30s I was 15 again for 10 years
so you had to breathe as an adult so
like get SNL so like in what I thought
was like the start of like the the new
thing was actually like being knocked
back
a little bit mental like you know like
it's like I don't think I really knew
what was going on is it when I was there
I really don't I think I was like
I was so taken it was very space camp
like I was so like
it didn't dawn on me till after
just going back I went like oh I would
have done this completely differently if
if I had nine years of of therapy I'm
under my childhood is it because the the
the behaviors that you undertook I'm
projecting on to you this is what I I've
done to survive intense Show Business
experiences were regressions we're like
going back to survival techniques coping
techniques you're talking about being
the guy that could take a beating or
like deal with a lot of stress but they
weren't necessarily the healthiest ways
to deal with them no the ask you're
being asked to do this very remarkable
thing and you were under equipped you
hadn't learned how but I could do it for
like you know it's like you didn't know
that's hearing you personally yes you
did it and in fact you were grateful
that you could do it you had this
imperfect fuel running the machine but
the machine was still running what did
you learn they that that made the
difference in therapy from that when I
went back I went I got a text saying hey
Tom Hanks is in town he's got nothing to
do he's here it's Halloween do you want
to do a um uh David pumpkins yes Mr
pumpkins he's mystery pumpkin yes
um
um and I was just like we'll see if this
happens sure and it was really nice to
not go like yeah
they picked me like you know it and that
was a an initial shock where I went like
oh
you're doing okay yeah like you're doing
a lot better what's between one and two
because when it comes I think just I'm
right now or I'm a place in my life
where I'm I'm good and I'm like I feel
okay yeah and I'm happy I'm I'm I love
my wife and my family and yeah we're
about to have another kid I'm like oh
really yeah and like just like
everything's great like uh like you know
work isn't uh as over like uh uh not
overwhelming um it it doesn't get to
Define omnipresent like just like you
know like
there was a big major thing for a long
time like it was SNL then it was another
sitcom then another sitcom and now it's
just kind of like a bunch of really fun
stuff and doing new stuff and I'm in a
different place everything's great right
now so you're saying once you I'm gonna
put my own twist on that
once you were vulnerable in other areas
of your life getting married is a
vulnerable thing having a family is a
vulnerable thing but you allowed to
trust other things to meet your needs
other than this weird I'm gonna say for
myself a dysfunctional pay to play earn
your specialness be the shiny boy you
start looking I heard Seinfeld talk
about family being like Neptune who
foreign
Jerry Seinfeld oh yeah I was in a movie
he directed
I know that guy
I want to hear about that TV show
Seinfeld yeah
he said when he got married and had kids
it was like moving to Neptune he's like
I've done everything they've done on
Earth let's see what let's say what
they're doing on Neptune he has an
amazing bit about uh uh family vacations
would you just calls them fight it just
calls family vacations but they should
just call them as fighting in hotel
rooms
it was very very funny joke to me but
once you move to Neptune now you get
these transpondences from Earth right
you what I mean is family started
meeting your needs you started meeting
your own needs and needing less David S
pumpkins
David has pumpkins the only reason I
went to SNL is David S pumpkins well no
Rita Wilson had a singing engagement in
New York and Tom had nothing to do
that's why I went back to SNL and
knowing that and not like they picked
and being able to say that sentence and
be fine with it yes is that to me is
precious was it finding anything about
yourself I know I'm assuming your wife
and child have helped you learn your
value outside of being chosen Chinese
Special
yes oh very much so yes you've learned
to forgive yourself accept yourself yes
yeah and when you were on SNL you were
more looking I'm not going to stop I
just need to continue to do it yes I'm
just I'm just more aware of it and it I
think at around that time I was aware
that I wasn't maybe being so kind to
myself or treating myself well or just
coping like you know what I mean like
I'm really good at just moving on and
just keeping like or keeping myself busy
and and or
you mean after the show must go on you
know kind of did you suffer like a
particular abuses like were there
moments looking back where you're like
I'm not looking this isn't a gossip SNL
yeah where it was just like every day 50
times
right I mean everybody did I mean like
yeah
what what shapes did those take punching
no she's belittling yelling I mean just
I think just general fear and tiredness
and uh every you know what I mean just
like all across the board and it's got
like that it's probably got a new yorky
flavor whenever we go to New York like
when I took Val to New York the first
time I was like in New York being uh
polite is being quick you go turkey on
Ride Like that's polite if you go like
huh what do you like you're an [__]
it's the opposite anywhere else so I
imagine even the new yorkiness of SNL
and the time of it and the liveness of
it pressure cooker and that must mean
people aren't very kind always oh I
because of SNL because of nine years at
SNL and the the the skill of the people
who put on that show any job that I have
had since then I am like we can do this
in three minutes
what you're doing can be done in a
commercial break can we speed it up like
I have like I'm like there's no there's
I'm like
when people come over and they like
start going like this or like they touch
my face like this and they walk away I'm
like that didn't need to be done like I
get like you're the guy that goes this
meeting could have been an email well a
little bit just because like the nine
years of just like it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter go the show it doesn't
matter multicam back to single cam
you're just like we could have been done
and that's enough I saw the different
end of the spectrum I mean Ted Danson
only works eight hours a day and like
from start to finish so it was like oh I
went from the hardest possible job you
can do hours wise and mentally I think
to the best Ted dancing schedule and
like it was real nice for for two
seasons you got to get in that dancing
yeah you do you gotta get in that dance
yeah the greatest I ran into him not
that long ago and he just seemed so
leisured
as an actor you are immediately aware
that you are around somebody who has
been in the business long enough
that they know how to Pace their day
yeah yeah that's right protect
themselves yeah yeah and my favorite
I've told it a million but I'm going to
tell it to you in case it spurns other
spurns spawns other uh spurns other
humans and other humans
Ted somebody was working with Teddy D
and after a take he walked back over to
the actors and goes isn't acting
embarrassing and I just think that's the
best I think that is what you almost
heard his voice when you said that yeah
it's just like that is so [__] funny
to me and so true it's true yeah it's
embarrassing there's a crew around and
you have to be like you
you can't talk to me and then yeah
you'll cut and then you eat Reese's
Pieces
that's a that's an insane person and you
look at your phone to see what's
happening in in actual life yeah that's
right it's crazy
are there any tidbits that you've
gathered about Show Business about
acting about whatever little mantras
like that acting's embarrassing
something somebody whispered in your ear
in a key moment a clutch moment anything
come to mind
yeah
nope
did Lauren Michaels really tell you to
eat a sandwich yeah he did yeah really I
thought for sure you were gonna 911
turtle that story
but this is why I feel okay well it was
like it was was I mean like I think I've
told that before yeah I I I I I'm gonna
say I am
99.999 sure that he came up to me and
said at one point went uh what happened
to my big guy when I lost weight and
then when I was uh what happened to my
big guy yeah like a little bit like that
and then when I was like the other one
like oh maybe maybe not that sandwich or
like like it was both sides of it it was
like too big
I remember the sentence you look like a
tick about to pop
he said that to you yeah
you look like a tinker about to pop and
I did but but also now I know like
I can I yes those those words were said
but the way they were said is is is
important yes and I can delineate that
now of like I'm not you know like it
wasn't chaotic and hectic at the time
but now I can go he wasn't wrong he was
trying to explain to me in a nice way
and I might have been a little emotional
and been like trying and he was just
like Bobby Bobby you know like he's you
know first thing Lauren tells you is
he's not your father but he's your phone
and
I think that's like I think that's the
sentence like I think like that for me
it was the was the the realization of
like a couple of those things were said
but maybe they were said for a reason
and uh and like and I'm and I remember
them now and I'm I I think I can
remember things that were said to me at
that place where I'm not happy
and those comments that he made before
that were not them
go like
like I almost go like I see why if that
makes any sense I know that's a little
victim blamey of myself but like
but like I truly mean it like it's like
I was uh
well maybe not maybe not the the
confusion of of making me battle against
myself that's a little rough
yeah and he is your dad
biologically we found out
Jerry Seinfeld who still I'm not
nothing's coming up I fee I see a face
but I don't know whose it is man
it's Ryan Hamilton in a wig Ryan
Hamilton's a comedian who looks a lot
like Jerry Seinfeld in my opinion oh
yeah when we come back we're going to
take a little break I want to talk five
minutes seems long what do you mean up
for a break I just want to say that
we're gonna take a 45 minute break it
just feels long I'm just gonna say that
right now we're gonna take a 45 minute
break
but you guys will be right back I do
want to talk more about food I want to
talk a little bit about what we'll say
did we talk about food well we're into
food now are we yeah we're talking about
him telling you to eat a sandwich oh
yeah okay so I just didn't make the
correlation now I have because that
sandwich is a food I didn't make my own
corn I guess I went more like oh we're
talking like I love good food and I got
like excited but then I realized you
were talking about trauma yeah
drama yeah
do you ever salvier trauma with trout no
we'll be right back
we talk a lot about anxiety and
depression on the show and I've
personally struggled with both and I
have friends who have been debilitated
completely derailed by both and I also
have friends whose lives have been
transformed by guided ketamine therapy
so I'm so happy to be working with mind
Bloom for this episode because sometimes
it's not as simple as a new therapist or
exercise meditation or Diet sometimes
you need something new to unlock your
brain and maybe that thing is guided
ketamine therapy from mind Bloom there's
a new tool to improve your mental health
at home ketamine therapy at home and
mind Bloom is the leader in at-home
ketamine therapy having safely helped
thousands of people overcome their
anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
antidepressants in fact in a study of
over 1 200 mind Bloom clients 89
reported improvements in their anxiety
and depression after only two sessions
it's incredible and right now mind Bloom
is offering our listeners 100 off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com
ymiw and use promo code
ymiw like you made it weird y-m-i-w so
take the first step and break free from
your anxiety and depression with mind
Bloom mindbloom.com
ymiw and use promo code y m i w we are
also brought To Us by our friends at
Blue land did you know we are eating and
drinking roughly a credit card's worth
of plastic a week yeah that's right the
products we're using every day are
ultimately contaminating our water
supply generating hundreds of
microplastics that we end up ingesting
luckily our friends at Blue land set out
to do something about it to eliminate
the need for single-use plastic in the
products we reach for the most like hand
soap did you know that an estimated 5
billion plastic hand soap bottles and
cleaning bottles are thrown away each
year and if that's not bad enough most
cleaning formulas are 90 water which is
heavy to ship leading to excessive
carbon emission it's a huge waste not to
mention the nasty ingredients in them
like chlorine and ammonia but blue land
is Reinventing cleaning Essentials to be
better for you and the planet by
offering endlessly refillable cleaning
products with a beautiful cohesive
design that looks great on your counter
just fill the bottles with water drop in
the tablets and wait for them to
dissolve hand soap toilet bowl cleaner
and laundry tablets all with clean
ingredients you can feel good about no
more bulking Cleaning Supplies on your
grocery run and refills start at just
225 that gets even lower if you
subscribe or buy in bulk I recommend
their clean Essentials kit which has
everything you need to get started and
comes in beautiful light sense such as
Iris Agave fresh lemon and Eucalyptus
mint and blue land has an offer just for
weirdos get 15 off your first purchase
of any product and get cleaning products
that I love the look of and love that
they're good for you and good for the
planet to get 15 off your first order go
to blueland.com ymiw you won't want to
miss this
blueland.com
ymiw that's blueland.com
ymiw all right let's get back to body
and we're instantly back for us you and
I are instantly back I know but for me
it was 48 minutes yeah we did take a
long extra but we took a nap yeah I fell
asleep it was a really weird I haven't
slept in six days is that true yeah no
how far along is your wife with baby
number two where do like Zoom wow what's
the age diff between the two
uh one will be six and one will be born
soon okay interesting because my wife
and I kicking that soccer ball around
and we're we're going like do we want
another one and we're kind of like maybe
it's just the three so my daughter's
already four so the six year difference
uh interesting some people say that's
the best uh we'll see I don't know first
time I'll be curious first time do you
make a lot of big decisions over kicking
around a soccer ball yeah I think that's
really smart I think that make that
makes it
physical it gives you something to focus
on while also uh making a life decisions
it's like you have your best ideas while
driving and true or yeah showering or
showering yeah some other activity I was
just thinking about that bathrooms and
cars Long Haul drivers probably have
brilliant I'm not making a joke I bet
they have brilliant ideas because
they're awesome William Shakespeare
oh long-haul driver William Shakespeare
what I can see a face
he was in B-movie oh yeah yeah yeah
tell me a Seinfeld directing you story
was he a good director what was it in
uh he made this movie called unfrosted
for Netflix and I can't wait I mean like
for Pop-Tarts yeah yeah it's like based
off of one of his first bits about the
creation of the Pop-Tart yes and it's
really cool and I I can't wait for
people I can't wait to if it comes out I
can't wait
Brian Regan also has the best one of the
best Pop-Tart bits of all time which is
like he's talking about how they have
instructions and it's like who needs
instructions for a Pop-Tart he goes put
the Pop-Tart in horizontally and he goes
oh he's trying to figure out which way
is the horizontal it's one of the best
bits of all time what was it like being
directed by a competing movie that's
coming out yeah I've heard that called
frosted yeah yeah you do want it on
frosted a frosted Pop Tart Is and Paul
Blart Mall Cop is in it as a character
is this real no is this real life didn't
they do like two of those Paul Blart
kind of movies it was like a Seth Rogen
one and a Paul Blart one he was an
Armageddon Deep Impact but I was just
that that's what I was he was the lesser
no but it's the Lesser known Armageddon
Deep Impact was Paul Blart and Search
and Destroy Seek and Destroy no um I
know what you're thinking but it was
stop and frisk stop and frisk nope yeah
no yeah I don't think that's it that's
not that what is Seth Rogen is in it
he's the Paul Blart in it
that's right
I was thinking if I was gonna laugh but
you just told me there's so many people
screaming at their oh yeah radios right
now but unrelated [__] you guys you're
saying it I don't know why I'm curious
with the sandwich thing
where you seem healthier happier where
how are you
I'm one of those guys on set I want to
eat my stress I want to eat my anxiety
I think if like
two or three years ago you had asked me
the sandwich question yeah and I would
have like panicked all night tonight
about like is Lauren gonna find out
there yeah I think that the reality is
that is like I think like now I'm okay
with answering a question like that
because I'm an adult I'm like well yeah
and I can figure out that like what's
funny that you put it that way because
if he's your dad then you're a child
yeah I feel less like a child than I did
when I was there I was a child but you
had to get out and and stake your own
claim that's a fantastic way of of
thinking about it yeah I was um
and I think I maybe have said it by
accident which is I felt more like an
adult when I was 15 and then when I was
on SNL I felt like a child again I felt
like right huh like especially coming
from UCB where it was like we're gonna
do improv we're gonna sleep in the
theater and we're gonna do it every
night for the rest of our lives yeah and
it's eight o'clock in the morning and
we're doing improv and it's not and it
was just like there was a mentality of
like you know like that and like SNL was
like do you guys want to go to the
studio and do improv and it was like no
like that wasn't it wasn't the same
let's all go do improv to get you know
it was I don't think it was the same
Vibe more Cut Throat where I didn't well
I think I was more naive I was more like
we did it we're at
and like
they were like I'm tired man we had six
shows this week you know what I mean
like it's like the reality of what was
really happening right my first couple
years was not there it's a
disillusioning I felt very Michael
Scotty I when I think back on my time at
SNL that to me is the way those two
words are are
I felt a little like Michael Scott like
I like I thought I knew what I was doing
but I I didn't and also you were very
excited as Michael Scott would have been
I like why yeah like you know like you
love him but right yeah you know yeah he
keeps stepping in it yeah were there
moments where you really stepped into
where you were just coming in with the
wrong energy well I just think I
misrepres maybe misrepresented I didn't
think I had no idea what was going on
and I may have just been better to say I
don't know what's going on or in certain
situations just not get upset I don't
know I just right you know you second
guess everything but also it's
I think it's this it's like Seth when I
first got the show I remember Seth
saying like congratulations you'll never
talk about anything else again and it's
true that was like the most true thing
yeah he's like this is going to be the
poll you're messing
um and like that's true and it's like it
always gets back to it ever if no family
conversation no matter what
everyone just goes like hey you know
that's great you wrote a book that's
great but let me ask you a question yeah
like no matter what that's in Jay
Moore's book he says he was in Jerry
Maguire with Tom Cruise and then he did
a late night show and they go from SNL
and he's like I was in Jerry Maguire
which is a very very big movie yeah wow
big part in a big movie yeah and it
didn't matter it's the guy from SNL
speaking of Jay Moore he had like panic
attacks oh yeah yeah anything like that
ever happened to you where your physical
state was getting in the way I have a
well yeah I I remember reading his book
like three or four times throughout my
time there and it was like every time it
was different like like it was like it
was actually like that book in
particular is a really interesting one
and was super helpful because in the
beginning it felt like a what not to do
at SNL guidebook and then by the end it
was like wow that was super helpful like
just hearings like like the podcast just
hearing somebody else saying I went
through this and this was my story right
in any capacity right was wonderful
because there's no not a lot of free
information over at SNL and that's
another thing that I learned at SNL
which is
the kind of you being in the one who's
in the room you know just like I'm not
the one who's in the room what do you
mean
there's a room where they make the
decisions and I am not in that room that
is not my job to be in that room yeah
and I think I always wanted to be in
that room yeah and I wanted to know what
was going on in that room and I think
now that I understand that it was not
not my job to be in that room and I was
better off not being me personally much
better off not being in that room it
seems that when I'm hearing you talking
about it now that there's a relief
like oh maybe David S pumpkins is back
David S pumpkins isn't back either way
Bobby's walking down the street you know
what I mean I wish I wish I could say it
was that easy but there was definitely
like I can't believe I get to do this no
I can't believe I could get to do and
from the moment they sent the text it
was the only thing I thought about the
entire was show week yeah 100 back
exactly where I was emotionally yeah
just like it's a show week I was writing
drunk uncle jokes just in case and then
that hat like it was like you want to do
a truck I'll go yes like you know like
well you have to act like it's cool
yeah all these note cards called drunk
uncle spell out it was just easier it
was that it was seeing that and going
like you don't have to just relax yeah
and I had a wonderful time and like just
going back and writing with the like
update guys and like
I was taken by just like I I it it
didn't dawn on me like oh my God like I
I'm about to have a two hour rehearsal
like I did this every Thursday and
Friday for nine years and like seeing
everyone so tired and gutted at the end
of the week and being like
but also going like oh it's so weird to
be in this room and like the two people
I know the best are Keenan Thompson and
Tom Hanks wow like you know like that's
weird like it's like everyone's gone
like it was like it was a brand new
thing so that was also helpful like for
moving on and like I haven't talked
about it in so long that like out loud
and not therapy and like it's uh no it's
very interesting process I guess of
course it is look at some of the
sentences you just said in that in that
last paragraph here's a weird one uh
last last performancey question then
we'll move into Bobby the man the sex
the sex stuff
I'm just curious as a person to this day
if you have a show the Hollywood Bowl
with the Muppets what are you doing to
get into a peak state for you to perform
like what is your nothing no I mean I I
that one in particular like
that
my parents were not there for that and I
wish they were for the sole reason of
like I had a baby like 12 days before
that and then flew to Calif moved to
California started a sitcom
started shooting a sitcom and did that
those rehearsals and did essentially a
full Broadway show with the Muppets yeah
at the Hollywood Bowl for like the first
time they had ever done that really at
the Hollywood Bowl yeah like something
like that like a show show yep now they
do it all the time and like oh I'm doing
it later today I was gonna say for my
did I get points off yeah I don't care
though I don't like how you're saying
that
that show was absolutely insane I have
no clue how I did that but as an
improviser and a SNL person and a
Hollywood bowler you don't have like a
thing like you have a show in three
hours what are you gonna do
oh
how are you getting that show in
particular I just chain smoked
cigarettes like I don't smoke anymore
and like I could quit for a long time
but I was extremely stressed and I just
remember standing like in the Hollywood
Bowl looking at it just going like and
the Muppets rehearsing and just going
like what is happening and I'm in a
corner just chain smoking going like
what is happening yeah I think it's that
just keep and then you just hear a voice
hey can I bomb one well
that I feel like that was life for 20
years was just like insane [__] like
that like yeah like you're walking and
you're panicked and you're dressed like
a moose and then Sarah Palin walks by
and pretends to shoot you with a fake
shotgun and you go that happened and
then you move on and then someone
slights you and then you're like what
was that about and then yeah yeah yeah
it was insanity
it's not as fast right you have the time
to process have you ever oh I do want to
talk a little bit about your parents how
did they pass and why six months apart
what's going on they murdered each other
they murdered each other that's the
worst it's still the worst a pill that
took six the worst joke I've ever made
in my entire life I didn't even feel
anything in my body uh uh they did not
murder each other
uh my dad uh uh uh alcoholic for most of
his life was sick for a long time the
end of it eventually uh uh complications
of COPD
uh smoker for a very very long time
um and uh uh uh my six months later my
mom out of nowhere
crazy thing and then um yeah supposed to
have surgery couldn't do it so listen
were you close with your very very
and I and then you had just gotten
married or you got married after they
passed
I was married uh uh uh so they were
there yeah had a kid
six months later dad six months later
like we're around there kind of timing
and that was maybe three months later
and then six months I I honestly don't
even know what it what shape did that
take in your life how much of it what
what kind of A disruption was that in
your life and what did it lead to
it was huge but like
so many things have been huge the
pandemic you know what I mean like it's
just like it was such an insane time for
so long that it is all now kind of like
melded into one chunk of like insanity
but one chunk of insanity that's your
next book yeah
um
what was the question what shape that
disruption took in your life like what
did it do to you
I think it just like everything else it
just made me a little smarter and wiser
about everything but also made me
realize that like that not everything is
that you can't let everything get to you
and be life or death you have to just
some stuff you just it happens and you
gotta
I think about my mom and my dad like the
best thing they could have done like now
like it's terrible but you think in
those moments like if I had to like my
dad was sick and like stuff like if I
had like if they were around for the
pandemic like I don't know what would
have happened like so like there's this
Cosmic thing of like those [__]
bowed out yeah on purpose like you know
what I mean like you know I like to
think like you know in those moments yes
died right before the pandemic it was
kind of like it's almost it it's
comforting to think that he was like I'm
gonna leave now you know what I mean
yeah there was a little bit of that like
I mean like the night my dad like you
know was like
yeah yeah it was there was a little bit
of that and and and
I think I learned that I think I learned
that uh I think what happened was like
child before that yeah a little bit more
on my way to being an adult now than I
was before I thought I was but I wasn't
right and I think that'll continue for
the rest of my life probably yeah and
that's okay and I understand that now
and I'm enough
God damn it yeah it's funny that Stuart
Smalley those things he says are kind of
good things kind of great things it was
like it was a great thing yeah I'm good
enough I'm smart enough and people like
me yeah it's it's it's not it's now it's
not silly now it's not a joke now it's
like because back then that story do you
believe it was even more Fringe
my wife
I'm just kidding sorry my uh my daughter
my wife and I really enjoy my daughter's
super into Wednesday Adams Adams Family
but it's so rough to think that like
when Adam's family came out the big joke
was like can you believe it he adores
his wife
can you believe this they're so weird
she likes him even though he's ugly and
he respects her
like and look at that was so depressing
that was the joke the big joke and like
they're monsters he's in love with her
he treats her well
can you believe that is with that like
it's like it's like the most I know he's
a monster but he was foreign too right
in the in the original one he had like
you know he had a certain Look to Him
and now they have adopted that look for
the Animated Series which is the
greatest yeah and then and like they
hired Louis Guzman for the show and have
Catherine with Catherine Zeta Jones it's
not conventionally handsome guy like
Royal Julia is very handsome yeah yeah
even then they couldn't right right
think of hiring somebody who wasn't
handsome like it's just like it's so
funny to me like that just dawned on me
recently and I like I love The Addams
Family now so much more I feel like it's
almost like I can relate to having like
I my best friend in in junior not junior
high grade John Candy John Candy my best
friend John Candy Uncle Puck to me but
um he no my best friend Miguel his
parents were like crazy about each other
they were Colombian and like I remember
that feeling like distinctly
non-american how like he'd like kiss her
hand and stuff so I feel like The Addams
Family was taking that sentiment that
it's like this isn't the dad at the
grill with the beer tolerating his wife
they like they're one of those clearly
sexually active couples that's like like
I remember looking through one of his
dad's journals I don't know how he found
it and he had sketched his wife naked
like and I don't think it was like a
secret it wasn't like don't look at that
it was like yeah your wife your mom is
beautiful I I drew her naked and it was
like I'm over here going like
you might this is The Adams Family to me
where's the hand
this is great where's the hand speaking
of monsters have you ever seen a ghost
a real ghost yeah not confirmed what's
in what's your unconfirmed ghost
I mean like I have think I have a
couple's
truth no I'm just kidding um the first
thing I thought of was me and Billy
Quinn in high school shout out Billy
Quinn um headed that out he saw a rock
in the thing he was like that's a
spaceship and I was just like you're
right and it wasn't a spaceship
um uh but we for we spent the whole
afternoon looking at the Quarry talking
about it and uh
um uh blazing weed no just looking at a
rock that was not I was not that kid I
was like call it again no just watching
a rock may have been playing GI Joes and
stopped to go to comment about Billy
trying to get me riled up that there was
an alien invasion in Eastchester and
there wasn't
um okay and I don't know if this is like
a ghost
story but like my mom had an experience
that she can't explain and she was very
much someone who never spoke about that
thing and only kind of talked about it
once where she talked about how her
father passed away right before our my
sister was born and that she cannot
explain it but she's like he walked into
the hospital room and said quanda
Sabella which is yours she's so
beautiful or in Italian and walked out
she's like I don't I can't explain it I
don't know but that happened and she's
like I don't know what to say about it
kind of thing and like we only talked
about it walked into the room she claims
like you know what I mean like and it's
like I don't know like you know it's
like and it's very well she's
I've been through a birth yeah so now I
go a million things could have happened
that made her really think that that was
true for the rest of her life yes sure
so and I'll never know now it's an
Italian doctor visiting she's full of
epidural somebody said it it looked like
you know who knows you know what I mean
like I have no idea how to explain that
sure or it happened or it was the Ghost
of her father and she just saw it for
that millisecond and uh some higher
power granted her a moment that will
stay with her and still until they're
inside all of us and now as well
undul love
um have you ever almost died
probably yeah
I think one time in The Galleria parking
lot I almost got hit by a car my mom
like dropped her purse I was real little
and like I think like I almost got
creamed right there but really yeah yeah
somebody pulled me out of traffic once
that's scary scary that we're walking
around with these human squishers
all the time and we get in them and then
we're the human squisher but it's crazy
that it's not happening more
I'm not a human squeezer right now but I
will be when I leave here isn't that in
your I was earlier yeah yeah
my friend
um oh John Candy my friend John Uncle
Buck to me Chris Mars had this great
joke about he was like he was like when
we get in our cars it was like then
you're a car and when you're walking
you're you're a pedestrian and you're
anti-car then he was like and then
people on bicycles are like blade
they're like day Walkers they can go
both ways like they get the benefits of
car they're in the road but they also
Run Red Lights you know what I mean like
yeah they're they're the day Walkers the
last time I was in I grew up in New York
the last time I was in New York
I was taking a car and looking at the
buildings and I got like real crazy and
I was like those are just all everyone's
in there like I don't know why like like
the sides of the buildings went away
like you know you just see like
Schenectady like you know what I mean
like Michelle take it off you just see
all the rooms and like individual homes
and lives with people I don't know why
like it really got me I think just not
being there in a while like I really
just looked and went this is bizarre
these are just ant hills man they are
they're stacks of people it's crazy it
was so I don't know what just and we
don't want to see it that's why it's
reflective glass it's like don't think
about what this is this is a building
it's an ant hill
[__] hey dude just a place to stay
you do psychedelics no no not now I mean
like I didn't really ever I tried I feel
like I tried everything once that's not
even true uh that's I I had my fun and
and tried stuff but then like it was
never being stuck I like smoked weed a
bunch that's it yeah but like everything
else kind of it's either this year or
this night and that's it or like yeah I
was I was never
that adventurous I love it I'm lazy all
around even in my drug use your comedy
partner is Charlie Sanders or was
yeah I don't know if you guys still do
stuff I've told the story before I'm not
going to tell it in its entirety but we
had an audition at house remember house
I do on the far west side it was like a
long room and there was like audition
things on either side kind of probably
not but go um it was on like 15th way by
the River on the West Side okay anyway I
had an audition there and it was for a
hidden camera Papa Gino's or whatever
dominoes
and it was it was they just wanted
improvisers they could pretend
to be chefs that that would trick people
would serve them Papa Gino's or whatever
it was they'd eat it and would go psych
that's Papa Gino's like in a five-star
restaurant hey guess what
and he was my scene partner
and we wept
I couldn't I can't just look at him
without people in the world that's what
I mean talk about Sinbad some people
just are funny he would just look at me
I'd be like Sinbad's his fault what I
mean like I mean like why I love Sinbad
like I think like we found each other he
used to tell me about this tape that he
had
but we're I look whatever I'm mangling
it oh Joe a joke that Sinbad did about
if Dracula was Teresa if man if a
Dracula is Jason you're just turn around
and triple yeah yes yes and just about
tripping Dracula and or that it was like
it's tripping is it's tripping your
girlfriend so Dracula catches your girl
that joke well it got mangled in the
retelling and we just bonded on that and
like we have us we love Sinbad together
uh I love it I likened him to Sinbad and
you guys like Sinbad together it's
pretty [__] weird
I just he's just one of those guys that
he would be doing a straight line I'd be
like guess what that's Papa Gino's and
be like what and I would just yeah he's
weep with laughter and we left and we
were like well that was a waste of our
time and we got callbacks we almost got
it of course yeah she's one of those
people he's one of those people like
Neil Casey that can just like he's he's
an assassin in so many different ways
like he's smart he's but he's also got
this like Alpha like it's hard to be an
alpha an emperor that's a real thing
like he's got it yeah like even just
intellectually yeah I think he's
let's do a speed round and get you out
of here it's been awesome well you
speaking of improv tell me
you're the greatest lesson you've
learned about improv uh something that
you hold on to that maybe somebody told
you that you take on stage with you
um a guiding a North star of improv or
just good advice for people that are
doing it
um
oh God I was gonna like try and say
something not real oh my God but like
where you're like look if you're wearing
shoes no I was I was gonna go more like
you don't have to do it for more than 33
minutes ever
like yeah keep it short I was gonna like
but I feel like that was slamming improv
a little bit but like I remember that I
also think is true now like I do think
that that's just because I'm a dad and I
want to go home yeah and I factor in the
drive now yeah but I didn't do that I'm
with you
um
I I honestly think now maybe it's just
like the the
UCB taught us all like the don't think
and the yes and and all that stuff but
then I just go like
I think the best part about like Looking
Back Now if I had to tell somebody or if
I had to tell my daughter what was the
best part about it was just like
it's it's less about the shows and more
about just like did you meet 20 people
like-minded people who find it funny and
like to go to the same place and do this
weird silly thing and figure it out and
not it was that it turns out it was that
yeah it was more just like
the whole experience of it was super fun
and like the Performing is super fun
like you that's where but it's like
that's the selfish part of it man like
it's like you realize now like this is
again a near-death experience you go
like wait it was all just an excuse to
hang out yeah yeah I love that what
about uh
uh I was gonna say comedy but that might
be too vague I'm gonna ask you is there
a great lesson you've learned about
comedy something that you hold on to
well now you say that more recently I
think it was like it was probably some
Tick Tock or something like I mean you
know those shows where it's just like in
a dark room and there's a circle table
and it's like
Oscar Isaac Benedict cumber patch Tom
Hanks
uh Jim Carrey like you know it'll just
be this story Fair presents yeah uh yeah
like this like assortment of actors
talking about acting and it always makes
me laugh a little bit like it's like
it's very funny like if like the world
was over and these were the only people
around
like we'd have like a pretty good movie
but that's
exactly yeah yeah um but it but but in
that when when you realize like we are
in this world and Tom Hanks he's sorry
I'm being long-winded he said something
recently about like Tommy Hanks Tommy
Hanks about working on maybe was Splash
and being friends with Penny Marshall so
he thought he was able to like go he
went to the dailies every day when they
watched the dailies and that was
something like whatever and she was like
she talked to him in a certain way
because number one because that's Penny
Marshall and she's awesome and she's the
coolest and because she was being very
honest with she was like you can't come
to these like we talk about you we make
fun of you like we might say something
you don't like like you can't come to
these anymore stop coming you're ruining
it like you know like well not only that
but it's also like it's not your job
it's not your place you don't need to
know this and we're gonna say you look
bad yeah where the lighting is wrong and
you're gonna take it personally because
you're an actor yeah and just kind of
the way he explained that of like being
in the room and not needing to be in the
room and knowing when that like that for
some reason recently has stuck with me
that's what you were just saying about
SNL you didn't get to be in that room
yeah it's it's it's uh or it's or
knowing when you need to be and that
it's okay that you're not because
yeah
that seems like a sh I was going to ask
you specifically about show business but
that's that's a great Showbiz answer too
it's like you know which room you need
to be in
right yeah what about marriage here you
are yeah married for a while now yeah
that's great yeah we're in a really
great place right now we're gonna happen
always no I'm just kidding hilarious
being stupid
um are you an Adam's family family
what are you going to say to them we
have a giant Butler if that's what you
mean
um I just mean what is a guiding star
for you for marriage to stay happy stay
healthy in your marriage
we we've gotten really good at that
recently where we're we're getting
really good now we had like a
conversation recently about how like
it's funny that like we respect each
other now and like that that's an actual
thing it's like a new thing like you
know oh you know what I mean where it's
like well no like you've been together
so long and yeah you know like when we
were kids like we had no idea and still
and like we went through everything
together and it's just like now it's
very funny to get to a point where
you're just like hey remember when we
were awful yeah to each other and we had
no idea yeah so all that therapy and
growth obviously helps everything what
about fatherhood the best I mean the
best yeah scary and like especially now
having the second one it's funny it's
like it's happening soon and I'm a
little like
oh yeah I gotta also think about that
too a lot more right but it's easier it
feels easier the second time you're like
I'll just get that baby and I'll do that
I'm like it's not that easy like right
like I gotta I gotta I think I'm I'm a
little bit naive right now before the
storm right
a little naive before the storm yeah in
the eye of the storm the storm is
here's this is I I've so enjoyed this
conversation and I I'm so glad that you
I'm how much do I owe you 75 I was gonna
say another session yeah 75 I have that
in on me great well everything shoots in
Canada I assume yeah
this is the last question but I want you
to
uh take your time with that meaning you
don't have to
feel rushed or booted
can you think of a time in your life
when you left I told you about what me
and Charlie that was one of the hardest
times I've ever laughed just tears it
was also because it's like church
laughter you're not supposed to they're
filming us we're [__] it up we're
blowing it but I couldn't look at him I
just start weeping with laughter then
eventually he starts stopping can you
tell me a story like that or a time in
your life maybe you were young maybe
somebody fell maybe somebody farted
maybe you were in church some situation
a funeral you're not supposed to laugh
can you tell me about a time when you
laughed so hard that you cried
uh oh I hate that one didn't just
immediately come to mind that's why I
give all the the falling farting you'd
be shocked how much it's falling and
farting
um
it could be SNL like pitching something
that was just funny I I have I have a
very distinct memory of me Jay Pharoah
and Cecily just one night just getting
like I don't know what like it wasn't a
common occurrence but we just got
hammered like at SNL one night and it
was just like Jay Jay Pharoah is a loud
dude and a drunk Jay Pharoah is even
louder and it was the it was just one of
the most chaotic and fun tiny office
experiences ever yes like those amazing
moments um
um but like oh God I wish I had like
you ever make someone laugh so hard they
threw up you ever poop your pants you
ever uh I don't have a story about that
but I can't tell it because that person
would murder who you no I'm just kidding
um you make it you make it me then I
have I have a very distinct memory of
making Lauren like there's this like
Lauren does this thing every once in a
while where he will just like [__]
lose it lose it laughing like turning
purple like when you get them you get
them really oh yeah you don't think of
him as Laughing I know he's a comedy guy
but you don't think of him oh that's the
thing but like when something like
really gets him and it almost like it
Spooks him
like you know what I mean like it's
almost like he gets a little like oh
yeah
I had great feeling because like the
look on his face I I you took a picture
of it I had I have a picture on my phone
of Lauren super super excited because it
it it's so shocking to see yes that it's
it like it's not you know he's I think
he's more known for his you know in this
tone not like that moment like
and I've seen that a couple times and
it's it's always at the best moment
because you're never gonna expect like
what it is and it's usually like a
little dirty he likes dirty for me for
that moment the one where I got him it
was like what was it dirty line
I think it just came out of nowhere and
I still kind of can't believe they put
it on air I did this weird character
called Janet Peck and Paul was like a
woman who the whole joke was just like
she knew she was older she knew what she
looked like and she would just walk up
to famous people and go like look
I know what I look like and the whole
joke was she was very selfish like I
know I'm like E.T when he dressed as a
lady
but why don't you just throw one in me
and like and she was very sexually
aggressive and I think it was I think
the line was to Adam Levine I said and
like I don't think I've ever used this
term before or after it was just like it
made me laugh that Janet would say this
at four o'clock in the morning to Adam
Levine I was like come on Adam I've been
flicking my bean all day thinking about
this
and I we got and that aired on
television and it did and I still can't
believe it
yeah it's awful I don't like it I don't
like it now it's not me and no one does
I my favors are different times I was
allowed to dress up as a sexually
aggressive woman and go on television
and sexually assault yes uh Adam Levine
it was not a great thing but uh he like
would
the dirtier and the weirder that
character got the more he loved it and
that always made me happy that's a great
great answer I've never had someone take
the hardest laugh question and go here's
the time Lauren Michaels left the
harness for me yeah for at least that I
remember where I was like oh I got him
like yes he made me giggle that that
made him just to relate by the way I've
told this many times one time I got
drunk uh fairly drunk not like [__] face
but like dinner drunk like three
cocktails drunk and I called Judd Apatow
dad
I just was like thanks Dad and I was
like
down for real oh this happened I did
that to my business manager right after
my mom died thanks Dad yeah my business
manager like gave me a very like good
pep talk about finances and she was like
okay and I went thank you I love you
and hilarious he said I love you yeah it
was a little bit like I was
still had my parents but I didn't
you didn't have to add that they
murdered each other six months after
each other yeah that's another favorite
onion headline businessman accidentally
ends business call with I love you
is one of my all-time favorites uh Bobby
thank you I'm glad we agreed that
Richard kindness Fozzie
that's a really good one I feel like not
body shape but Jenna from 30 Rock is a
pretty good Miss Piggy
you know do you know who I'm talking
about
Jenna Fisher yeah in her own no no no no
Jane Krakowski Jane Krakowski yeah Jane
Krakowski in the attitude of her
character that's great yeah not that she
looks like a foam Pig she doesn't look
like a phone no these days look you're
not gonna cancel me for calling Jane
Krakowski phone bill I think she would
agree and be flattered by that I think I
mean there's no other maybe Dolly Parton
with a couple pills in her yeah
who's Kermit
me no no um I feel like it might be you
get out of here a little bit well you
gotta who's Kermit I mean if I'm Kermit
I'll take it every day well I was saying
you like John Christians like Ron
funches Ron funches Ron funches winning
the Pooh there you go Winnie the Pooh
which is the Kermit of Winnie the Pooh
the Hundred Acre Woods yeah
it's archetypes oh my God and Tigger is
fuzzy yeah and we Are Everything is
Everything who's the owner of the
Muppets though who's the most Sam the
Eagle Sam the Eagle yeah
and he's our country yeah
there you go Bobby as Jonah Hill I'm
kidding would you say keep it crispy
it's how we end you say keep it crispy
and then we walk away keep it Chris
what a great Jonah Hill thank you
it was like he was here 22 Jump Street
23 Jump Street if we're lucky if we're
blessed thank you thank you
[Music]